all right you know what story was
written we are going to talk about some
serious stuff but you know what no we're
not
speaking of mars and aliens and whatever
other nonsense we've been talking about
check the story out from the daily mail
former director of the cia james woolsey
says he was skeptical about aliens
until a friend's aircraft was paused at
40
000 feet and he hopes we can be friendly
to the other creatures if they exist let
me say that again
until a friend's aircraft was paused
four thousand feet what's that like
tractor beam like who's it what friend
is he talking about
let's read friends a friend's aircraft i
thought that he said he saw it
he saw a friend's aircraft get passed
whoa
yeah or look i mean he could have had a
stroke yeah possibly
i was just watching star trek earlier
and it was the episode where time keeps
freezing
have you guys seen that one i've seen
them all they're in the they're in
the the the run about the shuttle and
then all of a sudden diana troy is
sitting there and everyone just freezes
like stops in time it's because there's
fragments of space-time continuum moving
like
shattering all around them and like a
mushroom trip oh my god
so anyway to then hear this story i'm
like that's what happened
that's brilliant crazy check it out he's
uh well as he said
that stories always seemed pretty far
out to me but there was one case in
which a friend
of mine was able to have his aircraft
stop at forty thousand feet or so
and not continue operating as a normal
aircraft what was going on i don't know
does anybody know
well says the source was someone i
respect john
greenwald jr the host pointed out that
the other former cia directors have said
they are open to the possibility of
alien life
in december john brennan told the
podcast he felt it was arrogant to
believe that we were alone in the
universe
life is defined in many ways brennan
said during the during the december 16th
episode now hold on
this story comes out right another story
came out another story comes at around
the same time what's up with this
nbc news drones that swarmed u.s
warships
are still unidentified navy chief says
the military is expected to deliver a
report later this year to congress on
the unidentified aerial phenomena
this is from april 5th 11 24 pm just
last night
they published this story a bunch of
naval destroyers have tic-tac-shaped
objects
hovering for 90 minutes at high speed
just sitting there
beyond commercial drone technology and
they don't know what it is
so marco rubio talked about it and he
was like whatever is going on with these
things
flying over our military installations
it's like a national security
breach like our security has been
breached and we don't know what it is
there's a major threat to this country
then we get this story coming out where
this dude's like oh yeah my friend's
aircraft was frozen at 40 000 feet
what is that all right so i think that
there's
aliens so i i think this could be
could be three different things and i'm
gonna probably forget them as i list
them but
um one i mean there could be some
technology
that china made that got in because
they're targeting the military bases
they're not no normal people are saying
this people in the government are seeing
these people in the military are seeing
this
i'm not seeing it you're not seeing it
you know what if it's an alien recon
it could be aliens that are like all
right we've targeted
the uranium i have no idea so it could
be aliens all right
okay i'll put it out there could be
aliens we could have aliens all right um
it could be that they do know what it is
but aliens are more interesting
yes um so it's gonna distract us from
whatever it is that is trying to kill us
or it could be that they just put
stories like this
out well they're passing draconian
legislation so we're distracted
i don't know i gotta look and see what's
going on in the legislature
yeah it could be that earth is a zoo you
know the great zoo hypothesis
oh yeah you guys know about fermi's
paradox lightly
the general idea is like if the universe
is so vast and massive
and life does exist then shouldn't we
have found some evidence
of intelligent life somewhere else at
some point and so then there's a bunch
of answers people propose like
there's the um the great i think was it
called the great barrier or something i
don't know
the great filter sorry that all life at
a certain point wipes itself
out for some reason one of them is the
zoo hypothesis that earth is effectively
a zoo
and that we're in a big cage where the
aliens come to watch us and giggle at
the stupid things that humans do
i think south park called it reality tv
that earth was just a reality tv show
for the aliens and they all watched and
laughed at us
and then they canceled us and they're
going to blow the earth up and then i
remember that
yeah yeah there's another really creepy
really creepy
um idea of what what could
what it could be why we haven't seen
anybody because the more intelligent
beings out there know that there is
something
that there is something bigger and worse
than anything in the universe they know
what it is and they don't want it to
find us
but we're stupid is that darkness yeah
there's there's something out there they
know about they don't want it to find
them but
it's like hey let's look for yep yeah
let's look
and we're sitting there we're sitting
there going like hello like you're
like it's like the friend who walks like
like the friend walks into the old cabin
where the murderer is like
yes exactly where are you i'm over here
and the murderer is like walking up
anybody here
that's exactly right they don't have
anything on me like that i know they run
they trip
that theory also it has a name i don't
remember what the name of the theory is
but it's like kind of give me chills the
first time i read it i'm like wow we're
dumb we're like yelling into the
darkness we're like yelling hello
i don't like the fermi paradox theory
that if life is here then why haven't we
thought shouldn't we have found it
because we just found out ice was on
mars
like six years ago and that there's
likely life within the wat frozen water
and on europa as well
one of them and we also speculate as to
would intelligent life develop emf
technology
and broadcast anything it's really funny
that we're live
we just started using radio waves and
now we assume
everybody to be using them i think it's
a waste
kind of a waste of money to a certain
degree like we're building these giant
space telescopes that i understand to
look at stuff
but then we also have seti search
extraterrestrial intelligence where
we're looking for like radio waves and
stuff
it's like that's still cool it's
something we should still do and i guess
the hope that we'll find alien life is a
good motivation to do it because we'll
we'll probably discover other things but
this idea that
in the past hundred years or 150 years
we started using radio waves and now
we're assuming other
intelligent life would use the same
technology they could be using like
light light fidelity technology you know
we have that now as well
where like fiber optics for instance
they could use
a laser that flickers to broadcast data
and we're not going to see that from far
away
you know something that i was hearing
that i don't know too much about this
but
one thing that i heard that they shoot
out into the universe is like math
because math is like universal
i mean unless you live on earth when two
plus two is five
but they try to they they they cast
stuff like that out
one plus one is two you know like things
that make sense
everybody unit is we're in a simulation
oh
there's no other intelligent life
because we're in a simulation
and what we're seeing these tic tac
things
they're they're game man mods you know
they're they're they're game managers
they're they're admins so that it's a
it's a nondescript vehicle a tick tap
that can move around seemingly outside
the laws of physics because it's
it's a it's a it's a moderator if you
think about when everything really
went to h e double hockey sticks was
when
they turned on the the atom smasher the
large hadron collider yeah that's it was
2012.
he got forced into the trump dimension
yup yup so and at the same time they
they you know they waived um they
repealed and replaced the propaganda act
at the same time they turned on the
hydran large house
can we make this movie can i can i like
is there a filmmaker out there who wants
to make a
movie about the large hadron collider
fires and it causes a big like ripple
rip ripple
space time continuum that blankets the
earth and then all of a sudden it's like
you see you see hillary clinton walking
up to accept the the the win
on on election night and then all sudden
it just like flickers and then she turns
into trump
and it's like and they're watching in a
protective sphere as reality is being
changed around them they're like
what have we done i think yes
there is and partly because you just
called for it
so i wonder if alien life is out there
and as soon as we say
alien life come to us it's like i have i
want to go in that direction
like inspiration strikes and
here's what i'm imagining like all of
these world leaders
are in this protective space-time bubble
as they're about to fire the large
hadron collider
and then they watch reality shift around
them and like hillary flickers and then
turns into trump and now trump's the
winner
and they're like what have we done and
the world leaders are like
we must fix this and they try to fire up
the large hadron collider again but then
a magnet breaks and they're like oh no
the machine's broken we're trapped in
this dimension and so then they have to
spend four years accusing trump of being
a russian spy
wall and they're like what have we done
it's broken fix it
and then and then they're like we're
running out of power and then and
they're like
no there was some kind of enhancement in
reality where trump is president
there was some kind of an animal that
got into that area yeah like a squirrel
yeah a squirrel or a crack or a monkey
some kind of animal that got into the
hatch i'm like you know what i'm like
the squirrel i'm like someone someone
turned themselves into this thing to
stop this from happening and they're
dead now
it's a squirrel and it's chasing it it
finds an acorn the acorn's bouncing down
the hill and it's chasing after it
and then it falls into a vent the
squirrel jumps in and the squirrel's in
the large hadron collider and it's
falling right when
right when you get to the middle of it
the the proton goes right through
and mixes with squirrel protons of some
sort it explains so much
and then it causes a ripple anti-matter
explosion
plus squirrel yeah but in all
seriousness there was an animal that did
get into the hadron collection
yeah i'm telling you the truth oh my any
idea what kind of animal i can't
remember but somebody can look it up
i remember i remember reading this story
about a dude who was at was in
a uh not the large hadron collider but
he was in a super collider
and something a proton a single point
like went through his head oh my god and
it messed him up in a really weird way
but didn't kill him
it just like screwed with his brain
because it was like my gosh what if
they've done that to like an article
around
they did that to all the dems yeah
everyone just got a single proton fired
through their brain and
now they're all like everything is woke
i heard this um this
incan scientist explaining the reason
the pyramids are there is because
protons are flying at earth from outer
space because our the earth's magnetic
core is negatively charged because
it's just iron and so the protons fly
through the surface of earth
through our bodies causing free radical
damage and then when they get close to
the center of the earth
the positive energy at the center forces
it to repel and go flying back out and
back through our bodies again
so they built these pyramids to channel
the positive energy on its way back
out and focus it through a point to like
gather it up from the surroundings so it
didn't cause free radical damage on the
humans
i got these egyptians were so so smart i
have an easier answer to
why there's pyramids all over the place
because people who didn't know that much
it was the easiest thing to build let me
stack
rocks like this there you go you bought
the structure you stacked some rocks
yeah it might have been like
also a tomb also a battery it was capped
with gold which is a superconductor well
if there was it looks like there's water
channels inside of it and if there's a
charge
like if the water was called ancient
aliens there's this thing called the
telerik current
in the earth that's like this low
frequency magnetic current
that flows and apparently it's it's
strong under where the pyramids are
tesla was working to lyric earth current
yeah interesting it's a it's an electric
current that moves through
uh moves underground or through the sea
to lurk currents result from both
natural causes and human activity
and the discrete currents interact in a
complex pattern the currents are
extremely low frequency and travel over
large areas at or near the surface of
the earth interesting
wow i don't know wikipedia says it's
true so it must be true tesla was
tapping into it and trying to send
electricity through the ground and
people obviously wanted to sell their
copper wires
so they shut that down but i think this
technology might be have something to do
with that with these drones or these
things that we're seeing flying around
uh they're charged by it possibly or or
it's on board fusion or it's like a
light
or it's like like a light refraction
that we think is a craft
i don't know maybe it's just like
solid-state batteries
yeah that someone developed and we don't
know they could just be there someone
could have just
developed it i mean they're watching the
military forces and they're watching you
know north korea and they're they're
watching all the targets but what if
it's just some dude in his basement
i mean you know like that's like lex
luthor level stuff yeah
having these drones that defy modern
technology
like jeff bezos i don't think maybe jeff
i love you and you're not lex luthor
but yeah your shaved head makes you and
and you know what i mean
and i've been thinking about too is mark
zuckerberg he's he's a really cool guy
yeah yeah there's nothing wrong with him
cool mark mark zuckerberg just great
jeff bezos awesome oh good got it i love
that amazon wouldn't be
experimenting with drone technology man
i love how it's like very obvious we
don't like them
i wouldn't be surprised if bezos has
like a secret lab where he's doing crazy
dude i mean that was the story
the guy who's doing global shipping
drones helping all these people
also secretly spying on american
military bases
it was funny when i tweeted elon musk i
was like i was like hey elon why haven't
you built an iron man suit yet and he
tweeted back
building starship and i'm like all right
fair point you know it's like
high point okay you know that's high
point yeah yeah unacceptable he's doing
the shield
thing is that isn't it he's building a
ship to go to mars didn't shield have
like a space in orbit nick fury's
no then the helicarriers you're thinking
justice league had the batman thing in
space
okay so he's doing justice league first
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you